no hearing how are you I'm good thank
you
now you are good your nice person in
real life we've heard Natalie tell us
but you've been turning the screws quite
literally on Theon this season at me
what's that mean like he had it coming I
think got it coming yeah it's been
really good fun you been enjoying it
happy inflicted that pain on him how
it's a distant and cruel do you think he
can get much worse
this is the beginning I think ya know
it's been nobody I really like Alfie and
we've had a great time working together
he's wicked actor he really gives it
100% every time and it was great to work
with actors like that so I've been
really lucky on the show as well of
course you've got another bad egg we've
got Joffrey who do you think's worse and
why Joffrey or your character and I
think Joffrey because he doesn't do his
own dirty work
so because you get in the mixer of you
saw I do it myself
yeah if something needs to be done do it
yourself in it of course it's all very
mysterious at the moment isn't it who
your character is exactly
I'm guessing kind of book readers might
have guessed but there's a lot of
unsullied non book readers out there so
when can we expect the identity to be
reveals oh I don't know maybe at the end
of this series I don't know diamonds is
gonna be a big shock do you think when
it happens I don't know I've absolutely
no idea I guess it's I mean the people
who have read the books and stuff
probably have an inkling and they've got
an idea um but yeah I think it might be
a shock yeah did you know that actually
on IMDB it had the name of your
character down there for a while it's
changed very recently just to boy what
do you think about that well you know I
I don't know who did that I don't know I
don't even know how to do it actually so
if you if your character got his hands
on them my god are they being trouble
yeah yeah you don't want to meet this
pasta there's a lot of really striking
deaths in the show on there if you had
to die on Game of Thrones how would you
go and use you think for the best stats
so far I mean it some trackers I mean
it's a big question I think being
beheaded would be pretty bad I think
they're the big ones only a couple of
them kicking about couple heads rolling
the end of your torture treatment who
would it be and what would you do to
them Joffrey and I couldn't possibly
talk about it on this interview what are
you gonna be looking forward to next
time you hear we hope you're going to do
some more music and hopefully do another
season the game of Thrones and then yeah
and see what happens after that
we look forward to it and the layers of
look with everything else and we can't
wait to see how bad he can go no it's
gonna get worse
trust me
you